So let's start with creating an arrayAnd
we'll name this array here animals.
And in this array we're going to take in
multiple stringsAnd the first string will be
bare.
The second string will be lyingWill add in a
tiger and lastly let's add in an elephant.
And the important thing to understand here
is with a raise
Each spot is indicated by index
So the Bears at the index of zero lion is at
the index of one
Two then lastly three
So normally you would think bear would be
one line would be two tiger would be three
and so on so forth but the big thing to
remember is it always starts at zero
And we can demonstrate this by console
loggingAnimals.
And we can use this square bracket
To indicate a specific index within this
array so if I'll hit two
I'll say expected outputShould be tiger I
should get this in my console.
The big thing to understand is we're not
going to get line here like I said we should
get tiger just because
of how indexes work in arrays a confusing
thing to remember those eventually will get
into getting the length of an array
and that will be actually one two three and
four but for now just remember the index
always starts at zero
So if we save this and go to our
applicationAnd if I actually serve it up.
SerpentSerpent.
Simple syrup
And in our console we get tighterPerfect.
They'll be more ways as we go throughout
this week to pull from the certain index
using four Loops for each Loops
but for now the biggest thing I want you to
understand just make sure you can Target the
array of animals
And then pick out the exact index by
indicating that index here
Awesome not from here let's go ahead
andActually make a variable out of it so
let's say let lion.
Equals animalsAnd lie if we check the our.
Notes appear should be at the end of one
So this will allow us to assign create
objects if you will from
Objects within an array
I'm just thinking about what if I don't
think I'm going to show anything else
So throughout this week we'll be going over
Throughout this week we'll go over other
methods we can have on an array such as
usingFilters.finds.
Even using push pop shift and unshiftLike I
said we'll use these later on in this week.
So you can get a better understanding of
what's going onWith the raise.
Another thing I would do want to show off
though is a raise can beDifferent. With what
information you're passing through.
So I can do a string for my first one I can
have a string again for my second spot
I can have a number of bull I can have new
null and defined and even not a number and
all
these are acceptable in this array and you
can always have a blend of objects within
your array as well
So let's go ahead and console log this types
array right nowWill say my types array.
It's actually not make that all one word
And this should output
And this should outputThis object from
above.
So if we go back to our application and look
at this console log
We see we get this arrayIt's like I said the
index starts at zero and we see we get that
first.
last 77 true null and so on and so forth we
get the length of seven
Sorry I didn't mean to do that actuallyLet's
go back.
We can also create an object
With an array in itAnd I'll show you we can
also add this object to an array.
So we'll say the same thing we'll have
animalsThis will have a bear a bird. B.
Let's keep it what's another good B animalA
brontosaurus no.
Dang Zack what's upBB. Bear B. Bird.
Bunny
And we'll keep with the B theme and we'll
just have this this will be a bunny
Next I'll put a bull on this object we're
just going to ask pretty much can it Fly and
we'll set it to false to start
Can it swimWe'll give it just a no.
And can it bearI'll leave that at zero.
The cool thing we can do now is I can
actually access that my types arrayTop push.
And we can actually push that Alpha object
into it
Don't put this in the video I'm actually
testing something I'm pretty sure it
shouldn't come backWell might actually.
Yeah I was thinking of filters sometimes
when you filter it won't you have to return
the rate itself
So if we console log this array again
soAgain so we'll say. My types array.
With Alpha object
We can seeWe should be able to see that new
object in that same array from before.
So it's refresh and we can already notice we
have eight items in this array
And we'll see we have this last object here
as wellWe can actually open this up and we
can get another animals right here as well.
With all the strings in itPerfect.
The last thing I'm going to cover is
actually going to be PEMDAS
I should really say the last thing I'm going
to cover before we switch over to the actual
Web application be building out as I'm going
to go over PEMDAS so the classic
ParenthesesExponents.
MultiplicationVision Edition.
SubtractionWe all remember this.
In the rule the same rules apply here in
coding so if you're ever going to make it if
statement
Something like this and you want to make
sureOne of the numbers so we want to make
sure x divided by.
FourBefore we want to do 5 / 4 we can do
that parentheses and say four times three.
Maybe we can make sure to use ourPlus three.
And we'll say is greater thanTwo.
Will just console log PEMDASI'm not sure if
this is going to be.
Greater than twoOh yeah I should be for sure
plus three.
So we do get that console log of PEMDASAnd
it's just.
And it's going to be similar to the same
wayBack in high school with or middle school
will do the four times three first.
And then after that we'll do 5 / 12And then
after that we'll do the.
Sorry
And then we'll take theValue from that and
just add it to three.
Let me just redo thatI was distracted.
So the first thing we're going to do here is
have the four times three so that equals 12
and then we're going to take 5 / 12
And then add 3 to itAnd this is always.
And it's important to always remember these
order of operations so you don't getDo
something where.
We'll take 5 / 4Actually sorry.
This time put that first so we'll do five
divide by four times three plus three is
greater than two
Why confused by the second one so much
higherCuz it's.
So if I console log
both these in here so
if I'm just going to
copy and paste this
Let's see if we get the same valuesAnd our
console log.
So let's save thatLet's refresh our page.
And we notice on the top when we get 3.4 and
on the second one we get 6.75
And that's just because
This bottom one actually my intellisense
went ahead and changed a little bit but it's
not respecting
These parentheses cuz they don't exist so
it's going to take 5 / 4 and then take the
remainder of that and time multiply it
by 3 and then just add it to three instead
of actually taking this multiplication of
four times three first on this top one
So just being very mindful that when you're
creating conditions or
Trying to create functionality trying to
create functionality within your project